The joe rogan experience.
So listen,
man,
last time you were here,
there's a fucking story
about the Russian mob.
We tease these bitches.
We let these people right now on Twitter,
they have been going crazy all day.
Do not let Bert Kreischer get out of
there without the Russian mob story,
man.
Tell us what the fuck happened.
All right,
this is in 1993 probably I
think is what I went to Russia.
I was taking Russian
classes at Florida state.
I thought they were Spanish classes
because I thought has been this classes
because I was a noon class and I signed
up and then I was like fucking sweet
Spanish at noon.
I get phone that in and then I get there
and they start writing a new language,
a new alphabet.
And I'm like,
all right,
this clearly isn't Spanish.
So then I said it,
I'm going to leave.
And the teacher's like,
listen,
don't leave.
Um,
because if you leave,
we can't have a class and I
can't get my master's degree.
So,
but if you stick around,
I'll talk to,
you have to have class.
I get done the end of class.
She was like,
listen,
don't,
uh,
you know,
if you don't leave when I
want to show up at class,
I'll give you a c.
I was like,
done,
done.
So I took Russian,
I took Russian one,
two,
and three because these kids need it.
Another guy in the class
to take these classes.
So then finally I take rush,
I'd take her out and
four and we go to Russia,
we go to Russia.
But this is Rochelle.
Like when the mob ran Russia,
like are you,
are you guys aware of that?
Okay.
In like the 90s,
late nineties mid nineties the mob ran
everything that had to do with Russia.
So when going over to Russia,
you had to,
you had to literally pay off the
mob in order to go and study abroad.
So we paid off the mob and they gave us
in return to banditos too young mobsters
who would go everywhere with us.
They lived in our hotel,
they stayed with us.
They went on tours with us.
They weren't,
they were did everything with us.
Their names are eager and
Sasha and when we got are,
our teaser was like,
listen,
this is Igor and Sasha.
They will be ghosting us with my
teacher who was there with me.
It was like during the fucking mob,
Igor,
inside you go inside and they were
guy named Bruce and they were like,
and they were,
oh,
it gets worse.
So they were like,
listen,
whatever you do to our class,
do not talk to them.
Do not interact with them.
Do not engage them.
They're only here to shadow us.
So in my head I'm like,
fucking get to know these guys,
right?
Like get a bottle of vodka,
a six pack of Baltic,
go knock on their door.
Now mind you,
I speak no Russian at the time,
no rushing because I had never
studied in any of the classes.
So first night there and knock on Igor
in Sasha's room and they're having a
party in there like fucking all
their friends are in their room.
They lived right next to me and Kendra,
my teacher,
and lived across the hall from Igor.
So knock on their door,
eager,
opens the door and he
looks like a fucking thug.
He's got,
he's got like a wife
beater on a cigarette,
a beer and he just looks at
me in Russia and he just goes,
Shh,
store.
And now as the second he
says that I start panicking.
All the phrases I had in my head that I
was trying to say all disappear and all
I say that you are in
Russian is I am the machine,
you know?
And so,
but I just said,
Ya machine though.
And he went stall and that
now I don't know what I said,
I'm like,
did it,
what did I just say?
I'll fuck you up.
Like,
and I go,
I go,
I am the machine.
And he goes,
say it again.
I said,
I have let me see him.
And then he starts laughing and he
brings me into the room and he's like,
hold on,
say it again.
And so I say it to the room,
I don't know what the fuck I'm saying.
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm the machine.
And they're like,
you're the machine.
I'm like on the machine.
I said that all fucking
night with these guys.
That's the communication we had.
As I said on the machine and Igor
and Sasha and I became best friends,
right?
We did everything together.
If we went on a field trip,
they would tell me,
machine,
you don't need to go on the field trips.
Come drink with us.
So now,
uh,
cut to one day,
we have to take a train to Moscow.
No different mob.
Ran The train to Moscow and a driven Tro,
tro Marbury and Moscow and Igor or Sascha.
We're not allowed to cross
boundaries and it's all me.
They said,
listen,
we're not going to go with you,
but we've taken care of you.
We've talked to the mobsters on the
train and in Moscow because we had to pay
them too.
They had,
they weren't allowed to come with you.
There weren't allowed to come with us.
And we're paying a different mob
now to protect us on the train,
make a different mob to
protect us in Moscow.
Holy Shit.
So they said,
we've taken care of it,
don't worry about it.
So they take me to the train and
they introduced me to our tune.
Who?
Gangsters?
Igor.
Where do you three words
at a Ford Dude's Igor.
And there's not a lot of names in Russia.
It's Alex.
Igor or Sascha.
What about fuel?
So,
so Igor,
Igor,
my Igor says,
so these are yours.
This is the machine.
If you give them alcohol,
you'll have a great time.
So even when you are
like through the roof,
they're like,
awesome.
Don't worry,
we've taken care of you.
We were sitting in first class.
You're not sitting with your class,
you're sitting in first class to Moscow.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit.
This is what I'm talking about.
And I bring another guy,
John Bolshoi,
big John.
I bring him with me to go sit
in first class and sure enough,
man,
I'm wearing fucking FirstClass.
Just meet these two.
Igor,
is John the conductor?
I shit you not the conductor
before the train takes off.
Comes into the room.
I swear to you,
rips off the band on this thing says
this is a present for the machine.
It would be an honor
to do a shot with you.
And I'm like,
Whoa,
this is a fucking right.
So I do a shot with its conductor and we
pound this vodka within like fucking 30
45 minutes.
We're done.
All the vodka in the room were drinking
hard and my classes all in coach and I'm
sitting in first class and even
Negro like let's go get more vodka.
And I'm like done.
They,
these guys run the fucking train.
So we get up,
we walk into the bar cart
and a biggie or says machine,
Grandpa Paulo grab,
grab some bread club.
And I'm like,
that's bread.
I'm understanding Russia.
He's like,
grab some,
see it as cheese.
I'm like,
I'm learning Russian.
I'm looking at,
John is standing behind me.
He's like,
Eh.
He's like gratified.
Can I go?
I know that one.
And he's like,
grab all the money,
grab all the approvals.
And I go,
what?
I look around and were
robbing the bar cart.
What the,
the bartender standing like this.
Everyone's standing against the wall
and I'm sitting behind the bar with a
handful of rubles of Bollenbach
in a thing of bread going,
holy fuck.
John looks at me.
And he's like,
just take it.
Let's go take all the fucking
cash out of the bar cart,
not making eye contact.
And they're their lunches.
It's the mob.
They ran everything in Russia.
Everything.
Wow.
And so we get done and we'd go back to
our room and it's a totally different
energy,
like very like very sketchy,
you know.
And I'm free talks.
I'm like,
fuck,
I just robbed the car like no
one else saw anyone rubbed.
The bark are except for me.
And my teacher vow,
who's at the time was our chaperone,
didn't speak any Russian.
She comes to our first class cart,
opens the door and says,
I need to talk to you right now.
And I was like,
listen.
And she goes,
I told you that you're in big trouble.
You I,
my classmate,
your classmates had told me what happened.
Big Ego.
It takes a sip of vodka,
spits in her eyes and goes,
no one talks to the machine like that.
I'm like,
whoa.
He spit vodka in her eyes,
fucking it is,
and then shuts the door and
then looks at me and he says,
don't worry,
I got you.
When it gets dark,
we're going to have a lot of fun.
And he pulls out a thing of keys.
He's got keys to the whole
fucking train and he's like,
we're going to rob everyone when the,
when it gets dark now I'm like,
fuck,
what did I get myself?
Like this is bad news,
bad fucking news.
So we get stark and sure enough,
then we start robbing the train,
go through my class first and
we'd fucking open the door,
the little eagle rock crawl
and pull the bags out.
John and I would go through them and
try not to steal like anything important
and Biggie or would stand guard.
And if anyone woke up,
he'd take us civil vodka
and spit it in their face.
And it was,
I mean,
it's sketchy now.
It's sketchy.
It's not even fun.
They low are these guys aren't fucking no,
no,
no.
They're loaded though.
They're hammered.
Piss drunk.
We robbed my whole class.
And then,
uh,
and then we ended up,
they ended up taking off and going into
the car and me and John are sitting in,
in the first class,
conscious thinking,
we're fucked,
man.
We're fucked.
We robbed the train.
We've probed the bar cart and they come
back and they're just fucking angry.
Drunk,
like Piss,
angry drunk.
We pull in a Moscow and my teacher,
Val,
uh,
comes to the door,
opens it and said,
I'm just sending,
you know,
we've called the police.
So it was like,
fuck.
So Igor,
Igor,
like,
fuck it.
Don't worry.
Fuck the police.
This is Russia.
Who the fuck she thinks she is?
This isn't America.
This is Russia.
We run everything.
I'm like,
Ugh,
I'm going to fucking go to the gulag.
Sure enough.
Sure enough,
man.
The cops are sitting on the,
on the middle,
like the middle,
you know,
were people get off the train,
that little receiving area.
My class is sitting there,
my whole class,
or in the pajamas,
they're crying.
Their bags had been gone through their
fucking giving statements to the cops and
the cops are writing them down.
And I'm sitting with Igor and
eager and John in the fucking car,
and they're just still drinking
and smoking and they're like,
fuck this,
fuck,
this will take you
there to this right now.
They walk outside out to the cops
and start yelling at the cops.
And I'm like,
motherfucker,
this is not how I would've
taken care of this.
Just,
I don't know.
I don't even know what they're saying.
But they were just shouting and
the cops were shouting back.
And then finally biggie or just
starts pointing at me and I'm like,
oh,
he's been in this whole
fucking thing on me.
Like I'm going down for the whole thing.
And then the cop starts pointing
to me and telling me exists,
is it?
Yeah,
it's by the ocean or whatever he's saying,
come here right now.
So I fucking walk out.
And it's that moment where you
find the hash on your body.
You know,
they find it and you're
going to jail forever.
Is that that moment that walk we were
asshole gets cold and you're like,
this is it.
Express fucking.
That's the moment.
And I walk all the way across
this little fucking trailer,
get to him.
I get right up to the cop and
the cop looks at me and he goes,
I understand you're the machine.
I was like,
yeah.
And he goes,
tonight,
you party with us.
So then we went out and
partied with these cops.
So the cops did nothing.
Fucking nothing.
They were so excited to meet the machine.
What it,
we're like this fucking,
it was the,
it was,
it was a nickname there.
No one funny in Russia.
Is that what it is?
No,
there was no,
there was no humor.
There was no so thing with you.
Is that what it is?
Is No one funny.
And then you come along
and you're hilarious.
So they like,
we're partying with you.
Yeah.
And I was,
and I was just loud.
Like there's not a lot
of Lao people like you.
Would you be willing to move to
Russia to be their bitch and to like,
Nah Dude,
those guys scared me one night the
guy did you party with these guys?
I partied with Igor and you were on the
train only and then I partied with the
cops in Moscow with John and then for one
night then we hid from them cause they
want it.
They like the cops.
The cops were,
were scary.
More scary than the gangsters because
they could not get in trouble like that.
You,
they were like crying my
cop car and you're like,
what the fuck drive my comp cost.
Fucking do they drive on the
left side of the right side?
Same side as us.
I don't remember.
I was there for three months.
You'd think I'd know.
I have no idea.
I was drawing on the same side as us,
but I mean like the whole
experience in Russia was just amuse.
Just,
I remember one time we
[inaudible] going to,
Sasha had said they were going to get a
boat for us for Russian may day or Labor
Day.
And they're like,
yeah,
we got to,
um,
they're going to have a big
boat for our whole class.
We're all going out in the boat.
So I get up early for the day,
we're going out of the boat and I go
over to eagers room and Igor is eating
dried fish,
drinking beers.
And I was like,
what's better?
And he's like,
I'm fucked.
I go,
what?
And he goes,
we got no boat.
Like,
what do you mean?
He goes,
I've,
I've tried everything
to try to get a boat.
I can't get a fucking boat.
And we've promised the class of boat
for the tour is supposed to have a boat.
And so we're like,
oh fuck.
And he goes,
and then all a sudden the
phone rings and he goes,
we got a boat.
I go,
we do.
And he goes,
yeah.
So we start walking to the dock,
we're carrying a fucking big case of beer,
my whole class cameras and fucking do
their little passports around their neck.
And one of his buddies just
walks up and he's like,
hey.
And he's like,
And then we just get to the dock and
there's a boat there and we just get on it
and take off and halfway
through we realize like I
just stole the fucking boat.
He just stole the boat.
And he was like rushing
must be just fucking crazy.
Insane.
We went to,
went to a big mob boss party
one night and he was like,
tells them my boss.
He goes,
this is the machine,
this is the guy.
Does this all happen?
It just was loud.
And then,
and then I was partying with Eagle
and Sasha so much that like that.
And they just tell their friends,
oh,
you gotta meet this guy,
you gotta meet this guy.
He's so funny.
We're going to have to drink
with you and then moved it down.
We're going to do shots
with Bert Kreischer.
You gotta be careful,
man.
You.
You are selling yourself as
this incredible fun party
guy and everyone's going
to want to do shots with you.
Oh,
I don't,
I'm,
I'm fucking,
are you friends with Igor on Facebook now?
Have these,
I tried to find them
on Twitter.
[inaudible]
Alrighty.